my name is Parshuram or romper short and
I work as a front-end engineer in
facebook as a web developer I've already
I've always loved this idea where I
could write any content and deliver them
across multiple platforms even across
the mobile web using responsive web
design using technologies like Apache
Cordova or PhoneGap I could pretty much
package all of this HTML CSS and
JavaScript into a native mobile
application and also use the device
capabilities no wonder when react native
came around I was super excited because
now I could build upon my existing
knowledge and not only create mobile
application but also make them look like
real mobile applications I'm so excited
about the idea of using javascript to
build mobile applications that almost a
1 year ago at this time during my
previous job I was building tools or
developer tools for react native things
like code push apps enter the vs called
extension for react native etc fast
forward six months I went and joined
Facebook and obviously I landed in the
react native team when I joined Facebook
I was really amazed by the amount of
react native usage inside Facebook a
majority of the internal apps inside
Facebook are written using react native
there are also tons of external apps
that I use that are written using react
native typically things like the ads
manager app that we prominently featured
on the react native web site the
analytics app and more recently the
companion app to react native companion
app to oculus all of these specifically
are greenfield apps or apps that are
written from ground up using react
native there are also other apps like
Instagram which use react native for a
bunch of screens and of course the main
Facebook app the main Facebook app
actually does use react native at a lot
of places including features like blood
donations crisis management etc react
native is also front and center in the
main main Facebook app so this button
that you see at the bottom the that's
the marketplace tab and that is
completely written using react native
and to give you an idea of what that
means this is something that has almost
or greater than 800 million daily users
800 million monthly users it it has all
it has more than a hundred screens with
many developers working across ma'am
across multiple commits and multiple
locations this is probably the biggest
reactive application that I have ever
worked on funny enough though this is
super large-scale the developer workflow
is very similar to what typically you
would expect all of the react native is
styled using JSX it's all CSS pretty
much in fact we even have a dev server
running we have Metro server running and
as soon as we make changes locally we
just hit command R and the familiar
loading screen show shows up and then
the things just work or at least most of
the time I mean I guess you get you guys
get the point but this definitely is the
largest react native application that I
have worked on and given its scale there
were some really interesting problems
that we ran into some things that you
some of the problems that you may not
really notice in a typical react native
application so let me play that video of
how I moved from the Facebook app to to
this screen but this time a little
slowly with an exploded timeline so
effectively what happens is when I start
off I'm on the main page and then I
click the marketplace tab as soon as the
tab click ends I see a gray screen and
the reason I see this is because the tab
has already changed but react native may
not have started up because this is a
hybrid app and because Facebook is a
really popular app we do not want to
start the JavaScript p.m. for every
single person so we start it on demand
and in this case we just started when
marketplace loads up for a very brief
interval you see a gray screen and once
react native is up and ready we show the
familiar loading screen while we send
off the network requests the network
comes back and then we display all the
content so that's where the content
starts now
though that gray screen shows up only
for a very tiny amount of time that
still is a visual jump and that does not
provide for a typical good user
experience now if we were to load the
contents let's say 100 milliseconds
later people wouldn't really notice
because the network would have already
taken one second so they're kind of used
to
but the the users who use the app expect
instant responses whenever they perform
an action so clicking on the tab should
have responded immediately rather than
showing them to gray screen a more
familiar or a quicker manifestation of
this problem is with something like a
set of lists so in react native if you
have to write a list view you typically
use a flat list now in a case where your
flat list is really really really big
with a lot of content shown on one
screen and if you are able to scroll it
really really really really fast you
might come across something like this
so the scroll continues but for a while
you might see this wide screen and then
once the white screen is complete you
start seeing the views loading up this
happens because react is inherently
asynchronous and through this talk we
will look at what causes this edge case
to happen what are we looking at in
terms of fixing these edge cases and how
does this whole architecture that arkad
new architecture that we are talking
about how will it help both brownfield
apps and Greenfield labs large-scale
react native apps and regular react
native apps to alike so let's try it
digging a little deeper into this
problem so how is a flat list really
implemented at the end of the day it
does a bunch of magic it does
virtualization but effectively what it
does is it only renders a subset of the
subset of the data so in this case
depending on the scroll position it will
just pick up and render a window of the
data now if you are scrolling say it
will probably show 0 to 10 and then so
on and so forth are the key to notice
here is the scroll action itself is
synchronous when you scroll on the
website you expect that data or that
action to be synchronous on the other
hand react native itself is very is
asynchronous and there is this impedance
mismatch that's the primary cause of
this problem now we did create react
native asynchronously for a bunch of
reasons and through the stock we look at
why both asynchronous and synchronous
matter and how does this whole thing
work into the new architecture so let's
just take that piece of corn and see how
reactor works internally first I think
that way we will understand our react
native exists today
and then we can look at what what the
future holds so this is a super simple
reactive component effectively what you
do is if you start off rendering that
with just one data on the react side you
get a simple virtual Dom tree then if
you add one more node there you would
basically be creating one more node of
the virtual Dom tree the thing to notice
is the virtual Dom isn't like thrown
away and reconstructed react the react
reconciliation algorithm takes care of
the fact that you have the minimal
number amount of changes required from
going from the old state to the new
state now if you want to create a third
one as expected it would not really
throw away the whole thing it'll just
rearrange the children and this is how
your code will look like the question
with react I mean this is how react DOM
and react native work the question is
how does this transform this JavaScript
stuff's transformed to all the things
that you see on the Android screen now
let's look at that in detail so as soon
as you start as soon as you start your
react native application you have
something called a route to you that
shows up and this route to you is just
the whole the top level holder and then
the react reconciliation happens so it's
basically a tree a concept that most of
us learn only during interviews but the
but but bear with me for a moment so
this is a tree it's a simple it's a
simple tree and what happens is it
starts at the bottom it starts issuing
commands over to the native side now
these come this command that you see
here on your screen basically is hey
native side go and create a view for me
the other thing to notice is though this
would be one text element that you may
have added on your JavaScript side that
itself might be a composite element that
means that you might be creating yet
another element just for that and
setting up a hierarchy so this is
typically how they tell how the commands
for creating a text element work on
react native once that happens you just
the other thing to notice is that number
three or the number two there so this is
a unique identifier that is that is used
to identify nodes on the JavaScript side
and nodes on the Dom side in a more
technical sense it's called the react
tag but effectively that that's that's
how all of these idea unique identifiers
are used so what what has happened by
it's a is that it said hey go ahead and
create a real create a react element
with a tag - and a tag 3 and then said
the child of three as - now now that
it's done with the text node it goes one
level up and by the way the other thing
to notice is each of these text nodes
have like both on the JavaScript side
and on the native side they have this
react IDs so now that text node 3 is
done we look at the view node 4 and the
view node 4 does a similar thing where
it says hey go on go on create a node
for me and then set the children and
then it keeps going up the hierarchy and
this entire tree structure is created on
the native side also now what would it
mean when you are create when you are
inserting another element so for example
here you are inserting the text called 3
what's going to happen in that case is
very similar when you insert like a node
called 7 it's going to issue the same
commands I'm just running it so that
it's a little clearer effectively it
creates the same hierarchy creates the
child element and then the interesting
thing to note here is instead of just
calling set children like in the
previous case it calls manage children
the reason why I want to point this out
specifically is because this manage
children is a command that's very
similar to what happens in the reactor
II console outside there's like a
one-to-one correspondence between the
way the virtual Dom is constructed and
different IFFT and to the commands that
I show to the native side so rather than
just setting children it's actually
manage children now you might think that
now that we have a native tree let's go
draw this on the UI that's not entirely
true there are reasons for it and the
tree that you see right now in the
native side it's not your it's not
what's drawn on the view it is what is
called a shadow tree so you have a UI
thread but that's separate and this
shadow tree helps to draw on the UI
thread and the reason why we need 3
threads and we need the structure is
because we do not want to keep the UI
thread busy so it's the shadow tree
where you take care of all the layouts
and it's on the UI thread your UI thread
is pretty much empty and shadow tree
does a ton of optimizations so that the
UI can be kept as free as possible also
whenever you hear people talking about
react being multi-threaded or react
native running on multi threads these
are the three threads primarily that
people are talking about so
let's go to go through the exercise one
last time I'm sorry you'll have to bear
with the whole tree thing but let's go
through this one last time and figure
out what happens when you add the third
node so when you are adding a third node
what I've done on the UI thread part is
rather than just showing 0 and 42 I just
made it a little more graphical so on
the UI thread you have like a like the
native hierarchy where you have a bunch
of nodes and I'm now going to go ahead
and add a new node on my JavaScript side
so I've rendered a new node as expected
you will get a bunch of nodes created in
the shadow tree this is very similar to
what we saw previously but the only
other difference to notice is because
the shadow tree is responsible for
layout all of the CSS properties in that
node that you have are passed down to
the shadow node so once this is created
the other thing that happens is it also
issues a command to the UI thread and
puts an operation in the queue to draw
that specific node some of you may have
already noticed that I did not issue a
command for node number 8 I also do not
have the green node or node number 4 in
my UI thread the reason for that is
because in the shadow tree it's all
about layout but there is no need to
draw the exact tree structure on the UI
thread
in fact the shadow tree 'adam optimizes
it and tries to figure out which of
these are layout only or which of these
are virtual nodes and it does not really
go draw the virtual nodes this way
what's actually drawn is super flattened
and super optimized so let's go ahead
and continue our process there is this
hierarchy that is set and again the
other thing to notice is because there's
a hierarchy set and because this is a
virtual node you don't have to go have a
corresponding queue operation on the UI
UI part you just Traverse all the way up
till you find the real node that you
want to draw in this case node number
one or the root node and then you queue
that operation once that happens this
queue is drained and all of these
operations are executed on the on the UI
thread the cute typically drains using a
whenever of frame ordering frame
boundaries and as a web developer you
may have noticed how you do
requestanimationframe this is very
similar the reason why you want to use
you want to drain the queue
do you especially during a frame
boundaries because you don't want to
interrupt an existing firm and that way
your entire and your entire UI doesn't
seem janky so this is the this is yet
another reason why you need shadow DOM
so that way rather than just sending a
bunch of commands over to the UI thread
you're sending it at the right intervals
so this is the overall picture of how
react native works let me quickly take a
step back here because I know that this
is a lot of things going on there were a
lot of arrows and I had to do tons of
animation and keynote pretty much broke
on me multiple times but just to
summarize react in react native there
are three threads there's a UI thread
which is what you see whenever you are
drawing something this is what is
displayed on your device there's a
shadow thread which is like a separate
thread in memory it's primarily used for
layout the layout is done using this
framework called yoga yoga is react
native snail framework and the best way
to think about yoga is you give yoga a
bunch of CSS and flexpa rocks properties
and it will give you the X Y height and
width of where something should be on
the screen and then finally you have the
JavaScript VM and that's where all of
your JavaScript runs here okay so this
is what the world is and once all of
this is done on the JavaScript side the
JavaScript reconcile here says hey I've
done all of this work I'm finally done
so it issues a command to saying hey go
ahead and dispatch view updates the
reason it does this is because though we
have added a child number 9 it kind of
looks incorrect I mean it's not really
placed properly or it's not laid out
properly that's because we haven't done
the layout paths right so we get this
dispatch updates and this is when the
layout path starts the layout pass
starts from the top of the tree and then
goes a post per child in this case it
looks at node number 3 it says that hey
there's no changes so it can skip that
entire subtree and then it looks at this
one the node number 9 where it says hey
that's a new node so I'll mark it as
dirty because I need to lay it out and
then it marks it looks at the next child
it marks that also as dirty and because
node number 9 might have to do something
might have changed the position of its
chair of its siblings it will mark the
entire parent hierarchy as dirty
now once that's done it goes through the
rest of the tree and this is at the end
of the day this is what my shadow Dom
looks like I have a bunch of nodes that
are marked dirty and all of this
information is compressed and taken in
into a draw command and add it to the
queue again just like the same queue
that you saw earlier once it's added to
the queue the next frame cycle it runs
it runs this queue and eventually you
end up in a world where all your your
your screen shows up so this is this is
pretty much how react native works from
starting when you start write something
in JavaScript all the way to the end of
the screen so how does this relate to
the problem that we had initially the
problem that we had was was this list
right so what how does this list become
snow because of this process I mean
isn't it common knowledge that
multi-threaded architecture is usually
faster I mean yes that is true in a lot
of cases using multiple threads is
faster but there are certain cases where
going across thread boundaries might be
more expensive than I the advantages
that multi-threading gives us so if you
notice whenever scroll happens you are
effectively sending an event from the
native side to the JavaScript side then
in the JavaScript side you are doing a
bunch of operations which is
asynchronous and serialized and you are
changing the shadow tree which then turn
there which then in turn put stuff
inside the queue and then the queue is
eventually drained to draw stuff so you
do not want to have this back and forth
especially when you're scrolling or
specially when the user is interacting
you want updates to happen almost
immediately so the best thing to look at
is let's look at each part of the system
and see where we can optimize so first
let's look at this layer so the question
is while this runs on multiple threads
does it really have to run on multiple
threads I mean does it really have to
run on a separate thread this is this is
threading and it's perfectly valid for
the network case or it's perfectly valid
when you want to render a large chunk of
data but the cost of threading is much
higher than the benefits when you want
to do immediate updates so the first
change that we are looking at in the new
react architecture is a way in which we
can pretty much break this thread
boundary down so rather than have it
rather than requiring the thread to run
requiring the shadow
to run on a separate thread we are
looking at a world where the shadow tree
can run on any thread what that
basically means is all high priority
updates like responding to scroll events
or responding to button clicks all of
them happen in the same thread as the UI
on the other hand low priority updates
like getting data from the network those
no priority updates can happen in a
separate thread if you've been following
the react architecture this is similar
to what fiber was built on and under the
under native the new architecture that
we're looking at derives a lot of this
goodness from the fiber architecture the
trick however is now that we have a
shadow tree and now that the shadow tree
is going to be running on multiple
threads how do you ensure that it is
thread safe
I mean multi-threaded programming is a
pain as it is and thank thank goodness
we don't have that in JavaScript but how
do you ensure that this shadow tree
works well and continues to be
consistent when there are multiple
threads trying to tell the shadow tree
what it should do one way to achieve
that is immutability so we are working
on converting the shadow shadow tree to
become immutable this way no matter what
what thread manipulates the shadow tree
the change will always be consistent
let's look at the second part of the
system which is this one so if you
notice what we are effectively doing is
we are creating a copy of every single
node in the JavaScript side we are
serializing it this is a sync and we are
creating it on the shadow tree I mean is
that again really necessary one way to
think of it is in the browser's when you
say document dot create element by ID
div the div element that you get the
return of that is not a JavaScript
object it's a native object it actually
holds a reference to the native value so
what is the call so though this this
system of serializing gives us cool
benefits like being able to debug on
Chrome or being able to run JavaScript
and a completely different machine is it
really necessary in terms of performance
the other change that we're looking at
is rather than rather than copying the
entire virtual Dom over to the shadow
tree why not we hold references similar
to what the browser does so every node
in the JavaScript world will now refer
to a shadow node and that is not
possible
the current architecture because the
wave the JSE structure is it's easier to
send cue messages so we are working on a
new interface a new JavaScript interface
between the JavaScript VM and the shadow
tree the side benefit of this JavaScript
interface is you will now be able to
replace the existing JSC that ships with
open source react native with any
version of your own a lot of people have
told us that the current JSC version is
very old and now you'd be able to
replace with a v8 or your or or even
upgrade the JSC as long as this
interface is confirmed - it's more of an
API specification the other thing to
notice is if you look at the shadow tree
itself it's written in Java the jost of
vm runs using c++ so so it's all
JavaScript code that's interpreted by a
C++ virtual machine yoga also is written
in C++ looking at that at this diagram
we were not very happy about the
language boundaries so why not convert
the shadow tree also to C++ this way
we'll be able to push the boundaries
boundary over to as close to the UI as
possible and now that there are three
things in C++ talking to each other it's
much easier to share data structures
it's much easier to share nodes and
other things across all of these all of
these three systems so in general this
is basically what the new architecture
of react native would look like the
interesting thing is none of the code in
the user lamp should ideally change all
of this will improve not only a large
scale applications but also impact or
improved real existing react native
applications now here's another example
of how this entire new architecture will
will improve a problem of will or will
improve a bug that has been sitting in
the open source key table repository so
there's this bug number 2 0 1 1 9 on
github issues which says that text input
gets become slow so the bug Bay you may
not be able to see it but at the top
there's a dropped frame count and as you
start typing more and more and more
things the text input kind of becomes
slow if you investigate why that happens
here's the here's the structure so let's
say you have this text input and you
type something like so and here's the
text inputs definition I mean this is
nothing fancy it just say
is whatever I type I said the state so
it's effectively a controlled component
so here if you type something say R
what's going to happen is a message is
going to be sent saying the text has
changed and you say hey aunt exchange R
then what's going to happen is the state
is going to get set and then because the
states states because I say value equals
this dot state or text I'm going to send
back a message saying hey can you set
this back - can you set the value to our
but what can happen is before this back
end force happens asynchronously I could
be super fast and could have typed a
second a second character here now now
that I have typed e this also gets gets
queued and it says hey by the way I've
already typed D so can you now change
the state from R to re now that happens
and the second instruction is also cured
and remember we already had the first
instruction that was cured so we we send
that over and the II that you see on the
screen will go away because react native
is now telling your telling the telling
your device head the value there should
not be re it should be R so the e will
disappear you become just R and then the
next instruction will come over and it
will make it re now this is not very
ideal and the way we kind of work around
it is we add a debounce function so we
have a debounce 100 milliseconds inside
the inside the text input code right now
that's not the most ideal but this
happens because of the whole
asynchronous nature and in this case the
users typing really really fast
probably in cases where they have like a
physical keyboard connected or something
like that
now if this was to look low the question
is how would this look in the new world
in the new world you type in are the
operation to change the text will happen
but because this can now be a high
priority update this can be synchronous
this is synchronous so you'll
immediately send a message back to type
in are when you type in e the whole
thing happens again so this is how not
just scroll views but a whole bunch of
other edge cases that we are now dealing
with will be fixed let me give you
another case another case you have an
existing native application a lot of
people you here have when I spoke to a
lot of people here they did tell tell us
that they have an existing application
and they want to add react native into
it so today if you try to do that this
is like a native list for example it's a
it's a UI
it's a uiview or it's like a
recyclerview or something like that and
if you want to add react native today
there's no simple way to add react
native into this native you that's
because react native layout is
asynchronous so you don't really know
what the height of the react native view
is so what typically ends up happening
is it gets added with zero height and we
currently have workarounds at least in
iOS where we say instead of using room
you use RCT surface view but in the new
world if the layout itself is
synchronous you don't have to go through
all these tricks you would effectively
be able to add the view and all of this
internal all of the layout happens
synchronously
so to summarize I think these change I'm
actually really excited about these
changes this gives me the ability to run
react native in both synchronous and
asynchronous mode it actually lets me
run my high priority updates or respond
or respond to user events in a
synchronous manner while continuing to
do like Network and all of these in an
asynchronous manner I am pretty excited
about react native and the long term
load roadmap that we are looking at this
is a long term project so this is not
something that we are going to drop
immediately and I am glad that we are
working on this because this will
improve the improve both existing react
native apps and brownfield react native
apps without having to have much changes
in the userland code that's all I had I
know that these slides were a little bit
dense so if you have any questions we
would love to answer you we have members
from the react native core team here at
the conference
preparing the Facebook t-shirt please to
come talk to us we are here to help you
my DMS on Twitter are also open so
either send me an email if you have
specific questions or want to know more
about it thank you
[Applause]